citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erickson alongside this guy
we're gonna watch How to Train Your
Dragon I love dragons I wrote a kid's
book that had a dragon in it so like I
love me some dragons now listen neither
of us have watched this wait go ahead
say your story you might have I have
seen this once I don't recall it he
doesn't remember
story of Greg was you know yeah
oh yeah he probably fell asleep he's
eating popcorn I remember being kind of
cute but everyone Raves about this
Trilogy like it's the second coming of
Christ so I I'm like I don't know what
that emotion is with this Trilogy so I
want I want to watch it again just don't
remember any anything that happens in it
so yeah I was like yeah I wanna I wanna
know I am ready I've never seen it don't
forget you guys need to leave like you
need to get on the computer you need to
leave a comment you need to leave some
fun comments and also ring the bell
ring the bells just subscribe because if
you're not already subscribed I don't
know what you're doing and also don't
forget to join patreon so you can watch
our full entire reaction on there on
patreon so come on get pledging and get
on get on that boat man Greg and John
cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included over at patreon so
now I think that we're ready to get into
it
this is Burke it's 12 days north of
hopeless and a few degrees south of
freezing to death
my Village and it's been here for Seven
Generations but every single building is
new the only problems are the passes oh
my God
we have
dragons
dragons cool my name's hiccup Bears
believe a hideous name Will frighten off
gnomes and trolls like our Charming
Viking demeanor wouldn't do that
wait is his name hecka hiccup okay I
recall that what are you doing out get
inside that's stoic the vast chief of
the tribe when he was a baby he popped a
dragon's head clean off its shoulders
Jesus
oh nice are you enjoying the party uh
Craig Ferguson meet head with attitude
and interchangeable hands is Goblin I've
been his Apprentice ever since I was
little well little Earth
I love these like handheld shots that
they do yeah it's awesome oh and that's
fish legs it's not loud the twins rough
done and tough nuts and
hello oh my gosh two minutes I'll kill a
dragon my life will get infinitely
better
you can't swing an ax
you can't throw one of these
you don't even know one of these are
will throw it for me
if you ever want to get out there to
fight dragons you need to
eat this
being a young white man
his voice is perfect yeah it's great
there's the Monstrous Nightmare only the
best Vikings go after those they have
this nasty habit of setting themselves
on fire
whoa cool but the Ultimate Prize is the
Dragon no one's ever seen
whoa a Night Fury that's a dope name oh
I wonder how much research went into the
set designs for this stuff it feels very
detailed
remind yourself the Devils still have
some juice in them yeah it feels like
it's an animated version of Game of
Thrones like sequences right now
give me something to shoot at give me
some
give me something I'd be so scared if I
was in his position I wouldn't I'd be
like come hang out you guys are cool
oh great shot
[Applause]
yes I hit it did anybody see that oh oh
[Music]
it's cool how he looks so large amongst
other humans but then with the dragons
it feels small yeah
just a couple of punches and then he's
off
oh
buddy sorry Dad
remembering some minor stuff like they
were father and son it's coming back to
mind winter is almost here and I have an
entire Village to feed winter is coming
between you and me the village could do
with a little less feeding don't you
think
I can't stop myself I see a dragon and I
have to just kill it you know it's who I
am Dad
it's like when the athlete has a son
who's a nerd yeah
if we find the nest and destroy it the
dragons will leave they'll find another
hole what Vikings it's an occupational
hazard now who's with me
today
he'd be killed before you let the first
dragon out of its cage oh you don't know
that I do know that no you don't know
that the voiceover work seems so natural
even as a boy I knew what it was what I
had to become hiccup is not that boy you
can't stop I'm stoic you can only
prepare him his name is actually Stoke
so
lose their knife for the mug no not me I
managed to lose an entire Dragon
oh I've been there man
yeah
what is this like a scary deep Trail
he's never seen before no I think it's
implying that the dragon crashed here oh
okay great
got it yeah oh love it I feel like
there's some great camera work in this
really feels like this really realistic
yeah like that's good great job on
perspective
oh this fixes ever
cut his jugular
[Music]
oh you're gonna love this Dragon this
dragon is so cute my high memory
remembers one scene you're gonna love
this track
it reminds me of my kitty that's exactly
why you're gonna love this truck exactly
like my kitties
I got out your heart and take it to my
father
do this I would never be able to do that
chicken you know
[Music]
they made eye contact
no
he could sense the animal Aunt I am this
is how Tara got her cats
forgive him he helped you
[Music]
yikes whoa
awesome
okay not the scene I was thinking of
love how visual that scene was yeah when
the eyeballs the eyeballs just starts
off so scared and you feel like it's a
helpless animal then it reminds you that
it could be a ferocious dragon oh yeah
that part
and the eyeballs
you go first no no you go first I love
other bodies are so different you get
your wish dragon training you start in
the morning oh man I should have gone
first
[Laughter]
can't kill dragons but you but you kill
dragons no I'm really very extra sure
that I won't it's time hiccups can you
not hear me
Father and Son story carry all of us
with you Walk Like Us
Talk Like Us
dad's not listening you just gestured to
all of me this conversation is feeling
very one-sided
welcome to dragon training no turning
back this feels like a it feels like
just a real movie like a real movie I
absolutely knew you were gonna say that
and I was like yeah it does not just a
kiss shots no just everything and the
voiceover specifically I wonder if they
just put lobs in a boom and they just
walk around as if you're in this scene
the script too feels like a real it
doesn't feel like make this for children
you know yeah
killed a Night Fury so does that
disqualify him you're small and you're
weak that'll make you less of a Target
all this unintentional insults
11 stealth times two the Monstrous
okay
aren't you gonna teach us first I
believe in landling on the job
cool if you get blasted
that
quick what's the first thing you're
going to need a doctor plus five speed a
shield go
Astrid is the [__] I mean that's a
chubby Dragon I'd just be like food and
throw it to him blur it with food make
lots of it throw off on Dragon's aim
all dragons have a limited number of
shots oh interesting wow but there's
always sounds happening that's one for
each of you
how many kids die in training on day one
they're Vikings they're vicious
laughs
pick up oh okay
oh wow
yep a dragon will always go for the kill
will it we've learned otherwise in the
forest by ourselves with the most
adorable dragon that ever lived
he does have like that scientist curious
mindset huh yeah because he's like also
just skinny and weak yeah he's like
Oppenheimer yeah totally he's gonna use
the dragon to create an atomic bomb on
its Firebird
oh
no
what's wrong with that he's done made it
stupid now Tara oh no go help him
we have the hiccup go wrong he's never
where he should be you need to live and
breathe this stuff everything we know
about every Dragon we know of you don't
know enough
me read while we're still alive
the words tell you stuff
now
so I guess we'll read it what a fun way
to make fun of youthful modern Viking
personality
a bunch of teens with so much angst so
it's really a story about him
challenging himself but his father wants
him to be and his history too yeah when
startled the thunder drum produces a
concussive sound that can kill a man at
close range well kill on sight
Timberjack here has razor sharp wings
that can slice through full-grown trees
kill on sight every every one of them
has killed yeah yeah even newly hatched
dragons can spray acid kill on site whoa
Broncos zipple back bone knapper
Whispering Death wow that's cool
sometimes buries its victims chokes his
victims turns its victims Inside Out
whoa dragons are taking a page out of
like Dahmer's book or something the
Unholy offspring of lightning and death
itself hide and prey it does not find
you
interesting they're close
steady
what an interesting world where
everything is just built around killing
dragons sometimes yeah I wonder like
what are what are you guys gonna do once
you kill them all I mean the dragon is
on your flag if they're gone what are
you gonna do with your whole theme are
usually like a backdrop in something or
they're like an animal oh my God their
boats are dragon boats yeah it's an
interesting world it's like everything
revolves around their identity with
Drake yeah wow their identity that
they're trying to like rid of today
it's all about attack
and light on the feet what a black and
white Maze Look for this blind spot
every dragon has one
blind spot yes deaf spot not so much how
would one sneak up on a night fear no
one's ever met one and Left To Tell the
tale now get it
Ah that's perfect this looks like a
peacock mixed with a piranha I feel like
all the dragons are based on some kind
of animal yes has anyone ever seen what
happened I love that he's still having
this conversation in the middle of this
it's great
oh
is this some kind of a joke to you our
parents war is about to become ours
figure out which side you're on oh man
what if he starts feeding information to
the Dragons It's like a super dark
family turn
oh my gosh
this is me every time I walk by my couch
with my two cats
toothless
could have sworn you have
I don't have any more
oh
oh how great this movie also has amazing
music yeah
oh my gosh the breathing and the look I
can't
so freaking cute
Bond
[Music]
s
I cannot stand how adorable this whole
thing is right now oh my God that was
perfect
[Music]
awesome
oh you're the way he does that what's
that called like a little like making
biscuits yes yes
[Music]
oh my goodness hell yeah
I love him what's he doing
oh
Wowzer cool
[Music]
touch him yeah give him a little pet
oh how beautiful
oh
[Music]
movies usually model certain mystical
creatures after like dogs or something
yeah
he's got to figure out how to build him
a tail how to build a tail for Your
Dragon
[Music]
cool
awesome okay so he was just like a
full-on inventor he's so smart
blacksmith but he's a full-on inventor
it's okay
yeah
oh he's out of fish you're out of luck
buddy hurry make it quick
oh I can feel it he's got his flights
back
so fun
come on
yeah there you go cool
oh my gosh that's amazing I did it
[Laughter]
no he doesn't
it like doesn't work without him on
there the Hideous simple back one head
breathes gas the other hand lights it
whoa racer sharp serrated teeth that
inject venom for pre-digestion prefers
Ambush attack question its victims could
you please stop that
chances of survival are dwindling into
single digits now
is that Christopher mint's Paws I don't
know like Lovin
[Music]
oh that one's fire get out of there
oh
what tricks have you learned hiccup
oh my God think about what you've done
he's like I love that like Chris Pratt
with blue
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yikes oh man
no
wow
oh so cute
it's like what's he doing
he's beating the dragons with love
oh so cute
so cool
cool oh that is awesome it's really cool
how we became a Dragon Rider by accident
yeah
hi Astrid hi Astrid
oh my god
oh and they're off there's like an
actual like tension to him getting
caught you know yeah because I'm like
please don't hurt him everyone is so
relieved by the old and then with the
new right no one will miss that oldness
Village in the life of a celebrity he's
very rough he can barely walk through
the village without being swarmed by his
new van it really is a beautiful story
yeah I just don't want him to get caught
in them to be like we gotta kill it
because it's a Night Fury like it's
there's so much wonder and Discovery
it's filled with curiosity
[Music]
I'm gonna go
this is beautiful
she was like Avatar also feels like
Soren the ride at Disneyland
[Music]
stay you got you gotta memorize that and
now you just got to go off intuition
[Applause]
oh that is horrifying yeah
oh yeah
the mountain oh oh
whoa
wow
whoa oh man
yeah just forget it there we go Instinct
wow
oh that is cool oh damn I got like
chills everywhere that was awesome
[Music]
oh
there it is come on
[Laughter]
Ah that's great yeah there's like actual
like weight and Dynamics to the
animation the physicality of it yeah you
know
not so fireproof on the inside are you
there you go oh my God he's friends with
all the dragons
oh oh my gosh they all behave like cats
I love them so much
little kitty dragons
just got to earn their trust and love
like a cat yeah
everything happens on this island
I would never make a statement like that
I was hoping for this I almost gave up
on you and all the while you are
you are oh no
oh boy
oh God heartbreaking
they have something to talk about man in
the ring
oh man it just creates more of a
distance between them it's half of her
breastplate
[Music]
God what is he gonna do it's so nuanced
it's like the dad feels proud of him but
somehow it just creates more of a
distance between yeah I knew it I was
like oh he's gonna be there and like
he's gonna be like what are you doing
this time for sure
do your thing okay girl
yeah great he did it so later oh not so
fast I'm kind of always
I hate it the Elder is decided
[Applause]
no yes I can't wait I am so leaving Oh I
thought they're gonna yeah make him do
it right then is he still there
oh man
oh
so you got me it's time everyone knew
drag me back go ahead
that's so great
friend oh man Astrid toothless
you wouldn't want to find out more
information yeah wouldn't you want to be
like how you cuddled up next to him he's
not eating you
[Music]
[Laughter]
now get me down toothless down gently
nothing to be afraid of
[Laughter]
I love it I love it
he's not usually like this oh no
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's emotional man I'm sorry just get me
off of this thing
oh that's all I needed here
[Music]
oh
that's cool
how transcending there should be a ride
somewhere yeah they should build like a
mechanical Dragon we could ride yeah in
the clouds
talk about perspective whoa that makes
me dizzy
oh my goodness that's beautiful
he's getting lost in the magic that's
what the dragons do man they drug you
with their flight
[Music]
this movie communicates so much just
right yeah it's a whole story about just
like enhancing your point of view and
changing your perspective opening your
eyes understanding it's pretty great
like to see her homework her hometown
from that point of view
what now
we continue killing dragons and keep
them hidden
tomorrow no toothless ain't down with
that you can't be killing no dragons
oh evil dragons oh
oh my [__] goodness
it looks like they're hauling in their
kill I don't know what's happening I
remember they're not bad dragons I don't
know what's happening right I'm like oh
they're flying in like a pack right so
it's like Fury just or toothless Blends
in
Mordor
oh the nest they were they were looking
for the nest oh yeah I feel like his
toothless heard what she said and maybe
decided like I'm gonna kill you I have
to show you because then maybe you won't
oh it's satisfying to know that all of
our food has been dumped down a hole
they're not eating any of it interesting
huh
whoa oh they serve the master the master
dragon we gotta get out of here all
right let's go upstairs oh that's a good
looks like a T-Rex dragon
it's like a giant beehive they're the
workers and that's their Queen it
controls them so the dragons are bad
when controlled is that what they're
saying the thing we've been after since
Vikings first sailed here and you want
to keep it a secret to protect your pet
dragon are you serious yes I think she's
saying yeah they're controlled by the
big dragon right so they're only doing
bad things to get the thing for the big
guy okay so yeah that's the reason
they're at war with the human okay I got
it give me until tomorrow I'll figure
something out
woke women standing up for getting
kidnapped oh
never in a million years do you think he
could get Astrid
I like how whatever the way it behaves
around her he doesn't behave like super
shy it's just kind of yeah himself yeah
no one's more surprised
my boy becomes a viking today he becomes
one of us
I feel so conflicted conflicted what do
you want me to do well he has to be so I
feel his oh yeah I'm like in his shoes
and I I'm like oh this sucks because
like he's been wanting to hear that from
his dad I'm ready
oh the one that's always on fire oh my
goodness
there's such a visceral way of capturing
some of these drugs
why I was doing in front of everyone I'm
not one of them
oh you didn't have to say that yeah you
could have just thrown the Hat down
buddy they're not what we think they are
we don't have to kill them I said stop
the fight
does that have another trick obviously
oh no if you're oh yeah yeah
no don't get hurt toothless no no
damn
no don't you dare oh no no no no no no
don't hurt him oh my God
no no
no
oh
that's no no I don't I hate it oh my God
I hate it
oh my God
oh my goodness he was just protecting me
they raid us because they have to
there's something else on their Island
dad so you've been to the nest oh God
toothless did only a dragon can find the
island it's not what you think you don't
know what you're up against it's like
nothing you've ever seen okay please oh
this is so
so unsettling you throwing your lot in
with them you're not a viking you're not
my son yeah some heartbreaking [__]
right there I mean like that was so
harsh but also I'm like oh my God like
parents are like that I mean it'd be
like some parents the way he reacted
when the dragon is attacking his son
like he there's no way he would possibly
understand where her son's coming from
like the perspectives make a lot of
sense
um and we don't know what happened to
the mom either you know right sounds
like she was killed from the dragon
stuff
[Music]
oh my God meanie I know it's not making
the dad very likable at all no like now
I'm just like oh yeah I hope your dad
dies like what a jerk I was weak I
wouldn't kill a dragon you said wouldn't
that time okay whatever I wouldn't 300
years and I'm the first Viking who
wouldn't kill a dragon my Stan was what
first to write yeah I would not first
the ride one first the tame a dragon I
wouldn't kill him because he looked as
frightened as I was I
probably something stupid
you were wise to seek help from the
world's most deadly weapon yeah it's me
I love this plan I didn't you're crazy
what is the plan train another dragon
and fly it to the hive I mean hiccup
could have really emphasized more of
what he saw too yeah
we're here wow that sound design is
terrifying
you're gonna need something to help you
hold on
oh my God they're all friends now no
matter how this ends it ends today
[Applause]
man the stubbornness on this
thanks
that was an amazing shot
oh now they're like learning they're not
there to like they see a bunch of you
and they're not trying to kill you
this isn't over form your ranks hold
together
yeah good luck get clear
whoa
what is that
it really does have like a dinosaur
aesthetic yeah
whoa
whoa oh yeah I mean your whole village
can be dead in one breath
okay well
no no no no no somebody let him go I
could buy them a few minutes if I give
that thing
summertime then I can double that time
give something a hunt you guys will be
haunted in a second baby
that's right as all as it mentions too
to compliment fish legs break it down
compassion and crushing steer clear oh
it's coming into play that's cool left
legs hang in his blind spot Make Some
Noise keep it confused rough tough find
out if it's shot limits make it mad oh
that's so neat I love it he's become a
leader that is so clever the subtle way
of showing how he becomes like his dad
but in a very different way
yeah it's a very nuanced movie
um
it's got multiple as you can see
multiple places at once hold on hold on
it's working yeah it's working
oh no it's affecting all the other
dragons too
oh my goodness no
what the hell
oh no
no toothless
[Music]
son of a [__]
hey season two yeah this room is badass
it's so good I'm sorry good for
everything yeah yeah as you should be
you don't have to go up there or Vikings
it's an occupational hazard
I'm proud to call you my son
whoa yeah
wow whoa I really don't want to capture
this like a monster probably tamale
oh he's gonna blow fire in his mouth
because they don't do well with that ah
get Astrid
oh did you get her
his room is so moving it's like a
perfect movie
damn those shots are incredible
whoa where'd he shoot him I don't know
just like on the outer blast was just
strong enough
oh that is terrifying I bet you he's
just gonna try to guide him away right
because like this dude's also a dragon
unless he's just like an evil one wow
that's awesome
[Music]
time to disappear
whoa oh yeah that big guy can't get up
there like that
it's such a weight like you could tell
her yeah so so much happier yeah
oh my goodness
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect shot you're in my territory now
that's awesome it looks like lightning
like a thunderstorm
yeah this does a lot of great stuff with
the elements watch out
okay time's up let's see if this works
what dude this is what works
wow whoa so imposing whole toothless
hub
one more time maybe
oh I did it man
that capturing scale whoa whoa that was
massive these flight sequences are
incredible
no no no no
no
uh
what
[Music]
I mean the dragons are all gathered oh
he's probably protecting him what if
he's holding him in his wing
yes yes
[Music]
oh my God oh my toothless looked at him
like what are you crying about
thank you for saving my son
most of them most of them
that's like my cat's at six in the
morning after going to bed at three in
the morning yeah
[Laughter]
I'm in my house
I love it
foreign
[Music]
oh did he lose like a lake or something
why did they say most of them
they're like matching he doesn't have a
wing and now he doesn't have a leg
realization you have to deal with
see that in an average movie something
like that that's crazy do not
oh he has to teach him just oh but he
could like hook it he could hook up yeah
oh my God that picture makes me like
want to cry because it's like it shows
the back of them and without like his
wing and him with his like new yeah it's
beautiful
oh
how it should be he changed the world
yeah or this island he changed the
silence turns out all we needed was a
little worth
this you're just gestured all of me
[Music]
the Zuri's got so much [__] art man
it's a great callback
that's for scaring me I'll lay one on
him
[Music]
oh cool amazing oh my oh my God I hated
it
are the pets while other places have
ponies or parrots visuals are phenomenal
yep we have dragons
wow what a great flip on everything what
a great flip
it really is the second coming of Christ
oh my God like literally this movie gave
me all the feels and I'm like
uh it's a perfect it's a perfect movie
yeah like literally no notes
they did everything right when when it
started off
because all the only thing I really
remembered
was when he's first bonding I had like a
slight visual of when it's behaving like
a cat yeah that's all I remember yeah
and and so I was like and I remember it
was called toothless so I was like all
right Toothless in the cat moment and
that Craig Fergus and then and that his
dad was played by Gerard Butler but like
the whole Arc and all that stuff like
none of that was this whole thing about
like a dragon hive mind thingy oh yeah I
don't know no no the all absent in my
brain uh and when it started off I was
like okay this is fun I over I don't if
it don't had slowed down after the big
dress
it would slow down after like the whole
like crazy opening it just instantly
started becoming this like amazing film
yeah like swept over me uh right away
and then when you see where it oh my God
visual consultant Roger deakins no
wonder looks so you Roger deacons is no
he's like a classic I probably should
one of the greatest cinematographers of
all time what else has he shot like we
know where to begin here let me let me
show you
oh that makes a lot of sense I just want
you to react to his IMDb for a second
he's like one of the greatest
cinematographers of all some say he is
the greatest cinematographer of all time
no wonder though the as I was like man
the camera work on this is so good yeah
um Roger deacons let's go to it oh Blade
Runner okay oh No Country for all men
1917 shot up oh he's I mean he is he's a
god he's a cinema God he works with the
best man oh wow oh True Grit wow serious
man that's a great um beautiful holy
junk Jarhead is such a good movie I need
to re-watch that his fish all Shank
Redemption oh my you shut the Big
Lebowski no he's a he's mean you guys
Roger deacons I mean it's funny like I
don't tend to look up the the DPS I mean
I should but
um that's amazing he's one he's
absolutely one of the best like
cinematographers of all time is
um I feel like looking at that he is
yeah so I I love this movie a lot like
the but the thing is like by the time
they get to that ending moment
with the by the time he gets the ending
moment what when they're bringing back
the narration and saying like all of you
going okay then that first few minutes
was perfect it was like absolutely worth
it then yeah because it sets up all the
the great callback right like the Arc of
it all yeah and I also love that they
arced back to like the the best thing
about this place is the pets where it's
now they they are pets living in this
world where before it's funny where they
were just like we're Vikings and we kill
and now the world is is so different now
they have pets and I'm like yeah pets
really do do that like you get a pet and
you're like my world's so different now
that I got a pet like what was I doing
before not having one like I wasn't
really living and I think too the
relationship between Hiccup and stoic
what a funny name Hiccup and stoic
because they don't have this exchange of
dialogue at the end of I'm sorry if he
says I'm just sorry they just say I'm
sorry to each other right but it's never
like I'm sorry for not listening to you
there's not this big monologue of
apologies and and Exposition dumping
your character arcs and the relationship
Arc they have they they just have like a
little bit of an exchange of I'm sorry
and it's the looks they exchange and
then of course the visual representation
of the drag is being welcome the
gesturing to yeah all of you
um that understanding that they can
never have with each other because it's
it's such a father and son tale and it's
got all these themes about perspective
and lineage and opening your mind hard
up there's all these different nuances
that are just laced throughout I thought
it was I I saw it I I definitely didn't
um before but this this was like this
really hit like this is a brilliant film
I mean I heard the sequels are like just
as amazing just as good or if not better
holy people people I know some people
who say it's like there it is arguably
the best Trilogy one of the best
trilogies of all time wow so yeah I hear
they're great that's insane also like at
the end when he's like I'm proud to call
you my son it's like during the entire
movie all he's hiccup is fighting for is
to hear that and for him to actually
finally hear it in in a way that he
wants to without it being said of him
faking his way through it being like
I'll be a viking and I'm gonna kill this
thing and I'll fake it and then like dad
says he's proud but then I have to live
with like oh the pain of it it was like
no it was done in a really nice way
where they didn't I feel like they
didn't waste time going through a bunch
of stuff that you may assume the tropes
that we would have to like hoop through
to make the relationship harder between
son and father so the payback is bigger
at the end I'm like the payback was just
as big and we got still a lot of time of
Hiccup training the dragons teaching his
friends that hey it's okay and we didn't
need uh more scenes of like him and the
dad and the dad being like upset or
making him like kill a dragon it was
just the right amount to give us like
enough of that juice so that the end is
quite the payoff which I really enjoy
but man I mean my favorite part of that
is that he lost his leg and now he is
like his Dragon like the similarities in
that I love that I think it's really
great writing yeah and I think it's just
adorable the visual mirroring and
symbolism is really strong yeah it's a
deep film with with fairies and it's it
this is like the definition of
accessible for the whole families
we're not like I can take my kids to go
watch it and I can muster through it you
know right sit through it it it's
something that truly is like yeah if
you're a kid I could totally see you
loving this movie and if you're an adult
you could I think you could pick up on
all these nuances and details where it's
like this to me is like a truly a
cinematic experience yeah I mean there's
like differences in when he's like this
is your mother's half breastplate on the
hat yeah that's an adult joke that kids
are not gonna get where you're like uh
that's funny like there's little stuff
like that with in the writing that is
not like they're not going to be like
we're hitting a a home with like the
kiddos it's like the kids are just gonna
like watching this and understand what's
going on right it's simple as like he's
got to train that dragon that uh keep it
cool hopefully nobody else kills the
dragon how is he gonna get through that
well the characters like can still be
like big and domineering but the kids
don't even I mean you could watch this
movie on mute and be like I like it yeah
like you know yeah well they they
illustrate the dragons in a way that
feels very kid-friendly but I love when
they get to whatever Queen dragon is at
the end yeah that it feels truly
monstrous yes like there's such a great
sense of peril and it's harrowing the
stakes are really high and it it the
whole thing gets obscured in darkness by
the end yeah and and the way the
characters all come around to each other
even even like with Astrid you know like
the A lot changes via through action and
not so much just through dialogue words
yeah right like with Astrid he directly
says like let me just show you instead
of trying to talk you into it right and
they go on a magic dragon right and you
know and then on the Magic Dragon right
she's she under she gets it like she
understands it right then and there and
then even the dad all he had to do is
see them all riding together and saving
the day and like oh I get it now you
know I think this is a great for for an
animation especi which is a visual
medium and nowadays they do a lot of you
know kids movies animated that that
don't really rely on just visual
storytelling and while it doesn't only
rely on visual storytelling I think they
have a Perfect Blend where the nice
bound they are taking advantage of their
medium to communicate a lot just through
the visuals where so much emotion is
felt via just through the visuals yeah I
agree I also think that him at the final
part of him teaching his friend he's now
found his tribe they're like his friends
and they respect him and he's become
more of a leader like you said like his
dad which is cool yeah which is awesome
but then he he has to go up by himself a
toothless up into the clouds to like
kill this most giant dinosaur ever and
he does it all on his own just by
himself so it's like in in turn he has
become the greatest leader uh and he he
does have to kill a dragon which is like
the whole point in the beginning it does
yeah
and it's funny that he he also has to do
it you know the irony of on top of a
dragon that he loves and that he trained
well yeah exploring the gray though the
nuances like not all dragons are bad
right uh totally that is very neat and
Toothless is just amazing like God I
just want to do let's just remind you my
cats yes I mean that's why you were like
you're gonna like this but yes it was
because they still keep him like a
dragon he's not just a cat he's like cat
and a dragon combined like he's flying
around my life that's a cat right there
you know but when he's on ground he's a
cat yes and and the the loyalty and and
um the sense of comfort too and the way
that it likes to be loved yeah and a lot
of the behavioral traits of being a
little bit Petty or snarky I think
there's a lot of cuteness to him and yes
of course the real heart of the movie is
the relationship with two between them
oh my God but one my other favorite shot
is when the dragon is trying to smile
and he's like
oh yeah yeah he's like shaking oh my God
that I just I love everything about this
movie for me I nine out of ten I mean
forget about it if y'all are like the
the other ones are even better uh okay
this movie was I loved it I really
really did I like it the last thing I'll
say is like the music too it's very
sweeping oh yeah and different though
like when you said this has really good
music it's I wasn't even picking up on
it at all until he said something it was
in the very first scene when he when he
spits up the the other half of the fish
right and it was very different it's not
like an atypical
Orchestra type of a sound it has like I
don't know especially in that scene and
then for the rest of it yeah it probably
did but in that one specific scene it
was different and it totally worked and
I really liked it that's part of the
maturity element I think too to the
movie is like the music doesn't feel
like a bunch of high notes kids music
yeah or is it like trying to be like
always heavy adult music or something
like that but it will you know yeah yeah
I feel like not noticing it but also
feeling the sweeping motions of it like
when they're flying uh without the music
trying to
the music didn't need to pull your
emotions into what was happening on
screen because what was happening on
screen you were already there with the
way the movie is but you know how
there's some where you're like the music
and the thing really yeah yeah trying to
force it in there yes and this one
didn't didn't do that and above all an
animation sometimes an animated
properties at voiceover work especially
you can when you're hearing a certain
voice you could I don't I don't quite
know sometimes it does the matching
you kind of feel like they got I feel
like they really animated around the
voice I agree like I'm Blended so well I
was kind of thinking like did they just
go why don't you guys just sit here and
do this scene it felt like they were
almost there right yeah and we'll just
like kind of animate around how they
gesture and speak yeah it felt like they
were in the same which is not I don't
know if that's the case but it really
got the impression because like Gerard
Butler plays the Dad and the way the
scene the scenes would go down I I the
blend of it because Jonah Hill is one of
them Jay baruchel's the lead and these
are voice actors that I've heard in
other stuff but it always sounds like oh
I hear Jay bearish show oh I hear Jonah
Hill yeah but here I just saw the
characters yeah you know and and I think
that's uh especially when you're getting
like celebrity voices usually you just
see this you hear the celebrity
absolutely and this one not really until
I was like I was really trying to figure
out Jonah Hill for like the first 30
minutes of this movie and then I was
like Jonah Hill yeah uh in my brain and
I didn't say it out loud but uh for the
rest of them I yeah I mean I think
you're right by like minute 25 you're
like you're in and you're flying it's
going you're like this is a great film
yes and then the first 20 minutes yeah
it's like some foundational setup stuff
yeah which is still good and
entertaining but yes once he gets the
tooth it's one yeah once he gets to
toothless it's we're off and we're
running that's when you're like oh this
is a this is something different yeah
way different like I love it so much we
should want you guys can let us know I
mean do you have any last thoughts
gregory no I've had like many last
thoughts the last 10 minutes sorry we
love this movie so much comment let us
know what you guys think uh we love you
so much don't forget if you want to be a
super sexy person join patreon and I
think we're gonna do a shout out let's
do it Tyler Hague if there is anyone at
our patreon page
who I would want to ride through the
skies it'd be you oh you're cuddly man
there's something about you that just
makes me feel so warm and fuzzy on the
inside
that I think riding through the skies
with you would feel like I'm right in
first class my friend that's so sweet
and then I could take Tara on the back
of me yeah he would make me fly in coach
for sure I would yeah yeah Tyler's been
large enough for there could be
different I feel like Tyler is like he's
gonna be like nope I'm an all-class
person and Tara is if she's flying coach
she's not even with us anymore no
exactly we'd have you
got it coaches in his butt got it
coaches his butt which is still comfy
depending upon what you ate that day but
yeah Tyler's got a great butt yeah and
does he work out a lot is it like tough
or is it soft and smooshy like a plush
or like firm mattress it's like a plush
plush okay I'm good with I'm good with
flush but he eats a lot of burritos
I think that I would like to cancel the
trip all together no refunds okay
I can handle it I mean I've handled gas
I mean I've seen the kind of menu
updated
[Laughter]
I think you can handle Towers but first
for three hours for a three hour flight
our flight to Colorado let me just ask
Tyler like do you hook up media down
there like are you able to sneak in you
know USB cord with an iPad
little lowly Tara over here just up the
I'm just saying if you got to shove me
up there you got to be having some
devices too
just you know like an iPad and like I I
still need like a I'm pretty sure a few
drinks it's gonna be entertaining enough
as it is in this situation I don't
really trust me I don't know just the
aroma of sense yeah I mean but once I
get over that it's gonna be like this is
boring well the odds of videos are gonna
pass out
I don't know I've smelled my own farts
before they can be pretty bad ah Tara
your attractive points just went down
way far yeah well
it's it's supposed to I mean I thought
they were already really down there I
know like I didn't even know still had
uh no it's a dot yeah exactly it's
non-existent try to find it we can't
well well this has been fun Tyler shout
out to Tyler for yeah
for just being being around Tyler
good luck with your butt I hope to never
see it or maybe I do
well when you didn't have as many
attractive points as you have yeah
you're gonna take what you can get or
this one
foreign